alors aussi est ce que les enfants de
stars sont privilégiés benjamin castaldi
vous dites oui bah oui évidemment parce
qu'ils ont ils ont la connexion ils ont
la facilité de pouvoir rencontrer des
gens à ce moment là après moi ce qui
j'ai toute ma souvent posé la question
quand j'ai commencé ce que tu es
pistonné pas dire non évidemment j'avais
la chance de connaître michel drucker
dans ma mère a appelé une chute au
hockey on envoie la benjamin il n'a pas
de boulot et ce qu'est ce que t'as pas
un petit truc pour lui c'est comme ça
que ça faisait aller pour faire un stage
je les lis comme on voir un stagiaire
pour né des cafés après il me fait faire
des essais il a clos en moi et c'est moi
ça me dérange pas tellement qui à
distance dans tous les métiers qui vous
êtes le fils de charcutier si vous êtes
du du talent ça me pose pas problème
vincent cassel sont son père était une
star vincent il a fait des éléments du
cirque il a travaillé et april bourré de
talent qu'il est le problème
carmat sera pareil donc honnêtement oui
on est privé parce qu'on a accès à une
chose que des gens du voyage n'ont pas
forcément accès mais c'est tout matthieu
delormeau
oui pardon je pas d'accord avec toi
effectivement ils sont privilégiés et
oui quel est le problème il ya un
problème effectivement tu le dis tu te
retrouves et chroniqueur sur france 2 en
access avec drucker
pardon mais bcc isner - faut passer
mille casting du monde c'était une
chance gigantesque est-ce que sans ça tu
serais là aujourd'hui certainement pas
malgré le talent est là où je dis
qu'effectivement wii est privilégié cet
avantage on sait très bien que plus
compliquée dans la vie c'est pas
forcément de réussir c'est d'atteindre
l'endroit où on veut aller une fois
qu'on y est qu'on est bien placé et bien
souvent on arrive à faire son trou qu'on
est un peu de talent ou pas forcément je
suis est le plus compliqué c'est le seul
endroit où vous voulez aller vendre la
collection
oui oui et mettre effectivement qu'il
est beau qu'il arrive 8e 10e 12e au 15e
peu importe
effectivement oui les privilégiés et
j'ai cette année normes avantage disons
le alors gilles verdez bien sûr c'est le
drame de la société française c'est une
société de pistonner c'est à dire que si
vous n'êtes pas si vous n'avez pas la
carte si vous n'avez pas la filière si
vous n'avez pas l'opportunité vous ne
pouvez pas exprimer votre talent tous
ces fils d'heure on dit parfois encore
faut-il qu'ils se fassent un prénom mais
il y en a pour qui il faut se faire un
nom et un prénom c'est beaucoup plus dur